we're with shamika and lee also joining
us uh is the biological father of their
children as well as 100 more
um and we are here to meet him i'm very
excited to have a conversation with him
ari nagel welcome to the show oh thank
you so good to be here
okay
i want to just ask what i wonder if
anyone else has the burning question
which is
why
do you do this
you know i'm from a big family so in
some ways i wanted a big family but
you know you do it once and you see the
mom is happy you see the kid is happy
and then you do it again and then it
just ended up growing and i was having
around two or three kids a year and then
i don't know this year i'm on track to
have 30. i had 25 kids this year so far
it's been very busy during the pandemic
some people were like getting into
baking and you know and i was just
expanding of course i was traveling a
lot
do you think
that there is any like god complex in
there
no that's a legitimate question you know
because i have a hundred children and
people like well why do you need more
kids you know but um if you look at lee
and shamika they each have one child so
if i would have told them sorry lee i
can't help you because i already have a
lot of children and i don't need any
more children when they would probably
say
yeah but what about us we want our one
child so don't focus on how many
children i have you would focus on the
families that i'm helping grow now
when you have your children
do you say
i'll be as involved as you want what are
the
sort of prerequisites is there a
contract
like how do you go into this
it's always up to the moms so there's
some kids that i see all the time and
then there's many kids that i've never
met i was in israel this past week and i
got together with two of my children
there but then the other mom didn't
really want me to come visit so that's
okay you know and i try and play a role
wherever i'm wanted or needed and i
think there's 100 different families so
each of them have a a different idea of
what role and it's dynamic it changes
all the time so sometimes maybe they
don't want me to play a role but then
maybe the kids 10 or 11 years old and
starts asking questions and then it
transitions into something else okay now
i just have to ask process
what is the process like yeah um have
there been
um actual
intimate physical encounters
the old-fashioned way
it varied so you know i have a hundred
kids so there's lots of different ways
to make a baby uh the vast majority of
them i just uh put it into a cup you
know and i gave it to them and they put
it inside it is the soft cup handoff
exactly and that uh that works it works
the same as if we did it the
old-fashioned way i mean it's
you've met people at you know
different places whenever these windows
arrive
that's right yeah okay how the heck are
you juggling all of this like i have two
kids
i am spread so thin
like how are you like legitimately being
like i'll be there to help you with your
kids i'll meet you there
who is running your schedule how are you
doing that yep
i i don't have any unpaid interns uh you
know working on my schedule so it's
challenging and it's especially
challenging because it's hard to plan i
don't know when they're going to be
fertile so you really don't know
sometimes to the last minute so like i
have a woman ovulating tomorrow in
atlanta and then on saturday in
jacksonville but i also have a baby
being born on tuesday so i'm going to
need to get back for that birth because
i want to be there she's a single mom so
i want to make sure i'm there for the
delivery room so i didn't buy my flight
yet but yeah sometimes it's uh
challenging and then sometimes you have
two women ovulating on the same day and
then you have to decide well who am i
gonna help you know so do you help the
older woman who maybe is running out a
time or do you help the younger woman
who maybe can try next month but has
probably a much higher chance of
conceiving well and that circles a
little bit back to a god complex like
who do you choose in that scenario
yeah well ultimately in the end the good
news is that they may ovulate every
month so you might say listen i'm not
free this month but let's try again or
sometimes i'll just work up the effort
and try twice in one day but ideally
that's not the best case scenario what
does the future hold for you do you have
any plans
what is re doing yeah that's a good
question you know what there are
increased risks i think for the age of
the male even though physically i'm
capable of continuing to have children
until my old age
i think that some people link autism
perhaps to the age of the male so
no i think uh my retirement's gonna
happen you know it's hard because you
know i'm going to jacksonville on
saturday for this woman who's ovulating
right and we have a three-year-old
daughter and she wants a sibling for her
daughter so what am i supposed to tell
her you know
it'd be hard so it would have to be some
kind of face retirement where if it's a
family that i already helped and they
want the same father for both their
children then that's something it'll be
a little hard to say no but maybe new
couples maybe somehow but you're mindful
that eventually medically things do
change for a male and you're cognizant
of every aspect yes and i think it's
different if you're starting a family of
your own but if you're helping other
women grow their families then they
could find someone younger of course my
son's 18 but he's not interested in
taking over the family business
well ari shamika and lee you guys
thank you thank you really and truly
thank you
for hanging out and listening to this
and everyone at home this was really
really
just
it's hard to put into words but i'm very
grateful to have this conversation
[Music]
you